tenemos aquí una matriz de 2 x 2 la
matriz
y digamos que sus entradas son a b c y b
ok lo estoy dejando muy general osea
estos pueden ser cualquier número porque
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar una fórmula general para la
inversa de una matriz cualquiera de 2
por 2 y lo que vamos a hacer es usar
esta técnica para encontrar inversas de
matrices que desarrollamos en los
últimos vídeos entonces lo que queremos
encontrar es la matriz
inversa y para encontrarla lo que vamos
a hacer es tomar la matriz
y aumentarla con la matriz identidad de
2 por 2 y ya que tenemos esto lo que
hacemos con esta técnica para encontrar
la matriz inversa es realizar todas las
operaciones de fila válidas que sean
necesarias para que este lado izquierdo
de la matriz aumentada o sea la matriz
original a para transformar la matriz
que originalmente era la matriz a a su
forma escalonada reducida por filas y si
esa forma escalonada reducida por filas
es la matriz identidad entonces nosotros
ya sabemos que lo que nos queda de este
lado con todas esas operaciones de fila
es la matriz inversa pero lo vamos a
estar haciendo todo el tiempo de la
forma más general posible con letras en
lugar de números porque estas letras
pueden representar cualquier número y
entonces vamos a obtener la fórmula
general con letras a b c y b de la
matriz inversa de una matriz a y así
cuando queramos encontrar la inversa de
una matriz específica donde por ejemplo
aquí este es un 1
pero vos o cualquier otro número lo
único que vamos a tener que hacer es a
esta fórmula que encontremos sustituir
los valores de adv dci de de toms es
pues vamos a hacerlo vamos a reducir
esta a su forma escalonada ha reducido
por filas y pues lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es hacer que esta entrada de
aquí se vuelva un 0 y bueno después
vamos a querer hacer que ésta se vuelva
un 0 y que ésta tenga la forma de un 1 y
esta vez también sea un 1 y entonces ya
tendremos a la matriz en su forma
escalonada reducido por filas igual a la
identidad ok pero empecemos por hacer
que se devuelva a 0 y para hacer eso
pues vamos a empezar a usar estas
transformaciones lineales que vimos en
uno de sus vídeos entonces vamos a
definir la transformación de uno
que nos mande a los vectores digamos al
vector x 1 x 2
aunque vamos a definir esta
transformación para que nos arregle eso
de que la ce sea 0 y pues si se lo vamos
a tener que aplicar a todas las columnas
pero nuestro objetivo principal en este
momento es hacer que se vuelva a cero ok
entonces a cada vector columna éste es
un vector columna y este es otro y éste
también es el tercero y este es el
cuarto a cada uno de sus vectores
columna los vamos a mandar a otro vector
columna con esta transformación de uno y
esa transformación pues al a todavía no
necesitamos hacerle nada entonces a la
primera entrada de nuestro vector
columna o sea a x1 lo vamos a dejar tal
cual así como está ok y a x2 a la
segunda entrada de nuestro vector
columna que al fin y al cabo es algo que
le vamos a aplicar a toda la segunda
fila a esa la queremos mandar a algo de
tal forma que justo cuando se lo
apliquemos a este vector columna esta
entrada se vuelva a cero no nos importa
que le pase a están ya están ya está
simplemente vamos a definir esta
transformación para que se se vuelva
cero y una forma de hacer que eso pase
es mandar a x2
a veces x 2 - c veces x1 acai porque
justo cuando lo volvemos en este vector
columna eso lo que nos va a quedar es a
x x2 que x 12 c o sea así
a menos que por x 1 que en este caso x 1
va a ser a menos c
y esto esto se va a ir a 0 ok entonces
esta transformación si cumple lo que
queremos que es que a éste nos lo deje
igual y a éste se nos lo mande a 0
entonces ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
aplicarle esta transformación a cada uno
de los vectores columna de esta matriz
aumentada aunque entonces apliquemos la
entonces a este vector columna a donde
lo manda pues esta transformación en la
primera entrada nos deja tal cual a la
primera entrada ok
aquí tenemos un x1 que es la primera
entrada de nuestro vector columna
entonces aquí nos deja un a
y en la segunda entrada de nuestro
vector columna nos manda a veces la
segunda entrada o sea
como acabamos de ver - ce veces la
primera entrada que es a y eso lo que
nos deja es un 0 0 y ahora vamos con el
segundo vector columna segundo vector
columna a ver veamos a donde manda t 1
este segundo vector columna en la
primera entrada tenemos la primera
entrada o sea tenemos b
y en la segunda entrada lo que tenemos
es
por la segunda entrada o sea de
- sí
por la primera entrada que es be
ve
y ahora vamos con el tercer vector
columna en la primera entrada tenemos un
y en la segunda entrada tenemos a por la
segunda entrada que es 0 - c por la
primera entrada
- por 1 y puesta por 0 es cero o sea que
aquí realmente sólo tenemos a ser por
uno y pues eso s
al cuarto vector columna nos lo manda a
la primera entrada es la primera entrada
o sea aquí tenemos un cero y aquí abajo
tenemos un a por x 2 x 2 es uno
- x x 1 x 10 y entonces 0 por cualquier
cosa es cero
uno por cualquier cosa es esa cualquier
cosa entonces aquí lo que tenemos es una
y ahora hagamos otra transformación pero
que haga que esta entrada de que se
vuelva cero entonces vamos a definir de
aunque qué te parece si dejamos esta
pila tal cual como está y eso lo que
significa es poner un x 2 por acá para
que esta segunda entrada sea exactamente
igual a lo que teníamos antes y en esta
entrada que es aquí donde denotamos que
es lo que le hacemos a toda la primera
fila pues lo que podemos hacer es algo
similar a lo que hicimos en esta
transformación que es agarrar esta
entrada como un escalar y multiplicarse
la a toda esta fila
y después agarrar esta entrada como un
escalar y multiplicarlo por toda esta
fila
y restar esas dos cantidades y así
seguro nos va a quedar un cero en esta
entrada porque lo que nos va a quedar es
este escalar por esta entrada de esta
fila - este escalar por esta entrada de
esta fila y pues como son los mismos
escalares que las entradas de la fila y
se están restando pues nos va a quedar
cero aunque entonces eso escrito en
términos algebraicos
tal cual hace menos veces
por la primera entrada por x1
- ve
por la segunda entrada y la segunda
entrada es x2 qué y entonces le vamos a
aplicar esta transformación a esta
matriz y lo que nos queda es a ver si se
lo aplicamos a este vector columna pues
lo que tenemos es a d - bc por a1
- b x x2 pero pues aquí podemos ver que
ve x x 2 como x 2 es un 0 eso nos va a
quedar 0 entonces aquí nos queda nada
más
esta cosa y en esta entrada pues nos lo
está mandando a esta segunda entrada y
eso es 0 ok vamos con la siguiente
columna y lo que tenemos es al menos bs
x x 1 y x1 es b
de bs
por x 1 - b por x2 o sea menos b por x2
es de bs o se ve da lo mismo porque son
conmutativo de menos de 6 y aquí podemos
ver claramente que esto es un 0 no
porque tenemos dos factores en cada uno
de estos que son exactamente iguales
tenemos aquí el b y tenemos aquí a de
menos b c y d menos bs ok entonces
estamos restando exactamente lo mismo y
entonces todo esto es un gran cero y
aquí abajo lo que tenemos es la tal cual
la segunda entrada de este vector
columna o sea tenemos por aquí a de
menos de c
pero para no tener que andar moviendo
tanto el pizarrón pues vamos a borrar
esto para hacer más espacio no
entonces aquí tenemos un cero y tenemos
nuestra matriz aumentada y de este lado
tenemos a d - bc por x1 que es un 1
- ve por x 2 pero x2 es menos c entonces
aquí lo que tenemos es menos por menos
nos da más y tenemos que el b y el c
pero estas dos cantidades se cancelan
entonces nada más nos queda un ave
y en la segunda entrada de este vector
columna de este vector columna lo que
tenemos que hacer es nada más dejar tal
cual el menos c
y finalmente llegamos al último vector
columna y en la primera entrada lo que
tenemos es de menos de c x x 10 x 10
entonces todo esto nos va a quedar igual
a 0 y es 0 - b por x2 o sea menos b por
a
menos
y en la segunda entrada nada más tenemos
que dejar tal cual lo que estaba que era
un a que y esta ya es nuestra matriz una
vez que le aplicamos la segunda
transformación y si logramos nuestro
cometido que era hacer que esta entrada
se volviera a cero
y si se fijan cada una de estas
transformaciones a lo que equivale es a
una operación de fila distinta o sea por
ejemplo aquí lo que hicimos fue tal cual
dejar a la primera fila en su lugar y a
la segunda fila reemplazarla por a veces
la segunda fila menos c veces la primera
fila y está así es una operación de fila
válida na hicimos algo similar con esta
segunda transformación aunque bueno a
ver vamos a limpiar esto para que no se
vea tan feo
entonces tenemos aquí en nuestra matriz
un poco más escalonada pero todavía nos
falta que esta entrada hacia igual a 1 y
que esta entrada sea igual a 1 para que
esté en su forma escalonada reducida por
filas y para hacer eso obviamente vamos
a definir otra transformación va a ser
la transformación de 3
y en esa transformación lo que voy a
hacer es tal cual dividir entre un
escalar cada una de las dos filas a esta
fila la vamos a dividir entre este
escalar para que nos quede un 1 en este
lugar o sea vamos a aplicarle
1 /
menos veces por a ok este es el escalar
por el que vamos a multiplicar toda la
primera fila o sea que aquí tenemos que
poner un x x 1 y por acá nosotros
queremos que esta entrada sea igual a 1
o sea que tenemos que dividir a esta
fila entre a de menos bs
/ d
- abc por x2
que vamos por la primera fila a la
primera entrada de la primera fila le
aplicamos esta transformación y lo que
nos queda es a de menos veces por hora
entre que es este x1 entre a de menos bs
por a o sea que nos va a quedar
exactamente en un 1 a la siguiente
entrada de la primera fila le aplicamos
esta misma transformación lo que nos va
a quedar es 0 0 por esta cosa de aquí y
esto pues sigue siendo un 0
y de este lado tenemos a the quest x 1 x
1 / avn - bc x
y pues aquí podemos ver que esté ahí
este se van a cancelar no y ahora vamos
con esta entrada
aquí nosotros vamos a tener menos ve por
qué es el x1 / a d - bc por a
y ahora vamos con la segunda fila a este
nos lo mandan sustituyendo aquí el 0 en
esta fórmula nos queda 1 entrega de
menos bc por 0 esto definitivamente es
un 0 y ahora la segunda entrada del
segundo vector columna nos lo mandan a a
de menos vez en que es x 2 por 1 / abc
pero eso es simplemente un 1 que bueno
eso pasa porque así definimos esta
transformación ok
y aquí nos queda menos se menos que es
nuestro x2 entre a de menos veces
de menos
bc
y finalmente a que es nuestro x2 / avn -
veces a entre a de menos
y otra cosa aquí en esta entrada también
se va a cancelar está con ésta
y aquí ya logramos reducir a la matriz a
su forma escalonada reducida por filas y
eso significa que esta matriz de por acá
es la matriz a inversa que teníamos aquí
en la matriz a que era
a ver
d
y ahora lo que encontramos es que la
matriz inversa es esta cosa aquí vamos a
escribirla en limpio porque porque
además esta matriz se puede simplificar
después escribir una forma que se ve
súper claro
la matriz inversa es igual a b entre a
de menos b c d
/ efe - bc y por aquí tenemos menos b /
avn - bc
- p / d - bc
y menos se entre a d
- bc - / de menos veces con que hay algo
que suena muy parecido no y finalmente a
/ avn - bc
/ ab - bc
de hecho cuando no estaba yo diciendo en
voz alta como que saltaban todos los
denominadores de cada una de estas
entradas son exactamente el mismo
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
sacar este escalar de la matriz entonces
a inversa es igual a 1 / avn - veces
por la matriz b
- ve - ve - c
c y finalmente a
esta es la matriz inversa
y tal cual así nada más ya hicimos una
fórmula para encontrar la inversa de la
matriz
para cualquier matriz de 2 x 2 ok pero
tal vez justo en este momento tú estás
pensando algo así como que hay pero no
todas las matrices de dos por dos son
invertibles como puede ser esta la
fórmula de la inversa de cualquier
matriz de 2 por 2 y pues tienes toda la
razón del mundo no todas las matrices de
dos por dos son invertibles pero para
las matrices que si son invertibles esta
es la fórmula de la matriz a inversa y
que es lo que realmente está pasando
pues que cuando una matriz no es
invertible esta cosa de aquí no está
bien definida
y ahora yo te pregunto a ti cuando es
que esta cosa no está bien definida pues
resulta que aquí estamos dividiendo
entre unos números y estos números
podrían llegar a ser cero aquí podemos
hacer todas las operaciones que hicimos
cualesquiera números abc y b pero lo que
no podemos hacer nunca es dividir entre
cero entonces lo que necesitamos es que
esta cosa de aquí sea distinta de cero
necesitamos que a de menos veces sea
distinto de cero
y con esta técnica tal cual si logramos
hacer que esta parte de la matriz
aumentada sea la matriz identidad
transformando a la matriz a con puras
operaciones de pila a su forma
escalonada reducida por filas nosotros
ya sabemos cómo vimos en vídeos
anteriores que si logramos esto entonces
la matriz a es una matriz invertible y
además que ésta es inversa y antes de
eso pues teníamos un montón de términos
muy elegantes antes lo que teníamos que
hacer era ver si era inyectaba y sobre
para ver si era invertible pero con esta
fórmula al menos para matrices de 2 por
2 lo único que tenemos que hacer es ver
que esta cosa de aquí sea distinta de
cero
ok porque si esta cosa de aquí es
distinta de cero entonces si podemos
hacer que estas cosas se vuelvan unos y
con esto ya logramos reducir a esta
parte a la matriz identidad y así ya
encontramos la inversa de la matriz
entonces ab - vez es distinto de 0
implica que la matriz a es invertible y
es invertible
y bueno de hecho también se cumple que
si ya es invertible entonces a de menos
b se tiene que ser distinto de cero
entonces pues esta cantidad de aquí es
súper importante no o sea determinado
tal cual si la matriz es invertible o no
entonces deberíamos llamarla de alguna
forma no y sucede que esta cosa de aquí
ya tiene un nombre resulta que esta
cantidad todo el mundo le llama el
determinante de a determinante
y para abreviar lo nada más le ponemos
y comúnmente al determinante de a
también lo denotamos cómo ponemos a la
matriz
bueno la letra a y les ponemos unas
barras grandotas por acá de hecho
algunas veces también se pone así como
el determinante y aquí adentro la matriz
de la matriz
pero pues también hay algunas personas
que piensan que es demasiado poner los
brackets bueno los paréntesis de la
matriz y además estas cosas que de no
tener el determinante entonces terminan
poniendo simplemente estas rayas
grandotas
pero muy importante hay que recordar que
cuando estén estas rayas grandotas y no
tengan aquí el resto del paréntesis esto
se refiere al determinante de a ok que
es un número no es una matriz que es tal
cual el número a de menos veces en el
caso de las matrices de 2 por 2 y no una
matriz ok este determinante es igual a d
- abc y pues esta cosa de que este
determinante sea igual a esto es así
porque así estamos definiendo el
determinante vea que esto ocurre por
definición
inicial
de fini
entonces si tenemos una matriz
cualquiera digamos nuestra matriz
general
b
de donde todos estos son algunos números
que entonces nosotros ya sabemos que la
matriz
inversa es igual a 1 entre el
determinante de a
entre el determinante de nada por esta
matriz
pero resulta que hay una forma muy fácil
de construir esta matriz a partir de la
matriz y es que si te fijas está ahí y
está de terminan cambiados de lugar no o
sea a nos la mandaron para esta esquina
y la de que estaba por acá la mandaron a
esta esquina y pues b y c se quedaron en
su lugar pero les pusieron un signo de
menos
ok entonces tenemos aquí nuestra y nos
la mandan al lugar de la d tenemos aquí
nuestra d y nos la mandan al lugar de la
a y la b se queda en su lugar pero se le
pone un símbolo de menos y la c también
se queda en su lugar pero también se lo
pone un símbolo de menos
tal cual esta es nuestra matriz inversa
así es que pues yo opino que hagamos
algunos ejemplos ya con números reales
para que las ideas se asienten
y entonces qué te parece si tenemos una
matriz de iguala
234 lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar el determinante de b
por qué porque el determinante de b nos
va a decir si ves invertible o no para
que sacar esta matriz que es muy fácil
de sacar si de todas formas b no es
invencible aunque hay entonces el
determinante debe es a d
este es a este sea uno por 4 1 por 4 -
bc este es de esta s o sea que tenemos
menos b
x
y eso que es igual eso es 4 - 2 por 3 6
o sea 4 6 es igual a menos 2 el
determinante de b es igual a menos 2 y
como menos 2 es distinto de 0 eso nos
dice que ves si es invertible y además
ya tenemos esta parte de la matriz
inversa debe o sea que aquí tenemos que
ver inversa es igual a 1 entre el
determinante debe que en este caso es
menos 21 entre menos 2 por la matriz
que nos queda de invertir estos dos del
lugar y ponerle un menos acá y un menos
acá entonces cambiamos estos dos lugar o
sea el 4 se va para acá y el 1 se
adaptará acá y que nos queda menos dos
menos dos y aquí nos queda menos tres
menos tres y si queremos dejarlo todo
perfecto pues nada más tenemos que meter
este uno entre menos dos dentro de la
matriz y de eso lo que nos queda cuatro
entre menos dos eso es menos dos menos
dos entre menos dos esto es un 1 menos 3
entre menos 2 eso es 3 medios y 1 entre
menos 2 es menos 1 / 2 gate tal cual
está es b inversa
estuvo bien rápido no entonces yo digo
que tenemos que hacer otro ejemplo ahora
vamos a tomar la matriz se iguala 13
6 así es que empecemos con el
determinante de c
y el determinante de c es de bs que en
este caso es a de menos bs si se fijan
tal cual lo que estamos haciendo es
tomar esta diagonal y multiplicar la y
luego restarle esta diagonal entonces
nos queda 1 por 6 1 por 6 menos 3 por 2
3 por 2 y eso fue de 6 menos 6 y eso es
exactamente igual a 0
y eso lo que significa es que la matriz
ce no es invertible ok porque si fuera
invertible éste sería distinto de 0 y
como te puedes imaginar pues puse este
ejemplo a propósito para que tengamos
una matriz que no sea invertible y se
puede ver desde la matriz claramente o
sea esta fila es dos veces esta fila y
matrices que tienen una fila que son el
múltiplo de otra de sus filas estas
matrices no son invertibles y bueno si
tratará de usar esta fórmula para
encontrar la matriz inversa de ce pues
aquí tendrías 1 entre 0 y eso no se
puede pero pues todo esto del
determinante viene
desde por acá cuando nosotros teníamos
aquí esta entrada que queríamos hacer
que fuera un 1 si nuestro determinante 0
nuestro determinante acuérdense que es
ade - bc o sea tal cual este término
si nuestro determinante 0 entonces aquí
tenemos un 0 y no hay forma en la que
puedan multiplicar esta fila para que
aquí nos quede un 1 aquí ya tenemos de
por sí un 0 entonces a la hora de
reducir hace a su forma escalonada
reducida por filas aquí ya tenemos un 0
que no se puede convertir en 1 por lo
cual aquí no podemos conseguir una
matriz identidad ok
estas son de las cosas más importantes
del determinante
que determinan perfectamente y súper
rápido si una matriz es invertible o no